[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the long talked about samsung galaxy
s5 so after the presentation of all its
new features i got to spend about an
hour of quality time with this new phone
so
here are my honest first impressions of
all this stuff so first of all the new
specs since you can't really avoid them
it has a 2.5 gigahertz quad-core
processor 2 gigs of ram lte and 802.11
ac wi-fi nothing too insane under the
hood here but definitely in the top tier
this is a high-end flagship phone so on
the front it's rocking a slightly larger
5.1 inch 1080p amoled display just a bit
bigger than the 5.0 inch galaxy s4 and
that right there is the symbol for
pretty much everything else about this
phone it's just slightly bumped up from
the samsung galaxy s4 in a lot of ways
but one way definitely did surprise is
the build material so the back of this
phone as predicted feels a lot like the
soft touch on the back of the note 3 but
without the leather stitching on the
edges but then for some reason they
added this unsightly bumpiness to it
like the dimples on the back
and i'm not sure how i feel about this i
mean it kind of reminds me of the
original nexus 7 plus some sort of golf
ball hybrid going on it's weird i can't
say i'm a fan of it right now but anyway
there are four colors the black with the
black front the white which has white
bezels the blue which i guess is
the least bad looking of the bunch i
guess uh and it has black bezels and
then there's also the gold which i like
to call the band-aid edition anyway at
least the build of this guy has a tiny
bit of reasoning behind it despite its
removable back and totally expandable
storage and totally swappable 2800
milliamp hour battery the galaxy s4 is
still
ip67 certified now now i'll leave a link
in the description to exactly what ip67
means but basically the six means it's
totally dust proof no matter how small
the grain and the seven means it's water
resistant but not waterproof definitely
a difference there but what's cool is
this doesn't seem to have a huge effect
on the build of the phone like i said
the back is still removable it only
leaves me worried about that speaker
quality so we'll see how that turns out
anyway i think i played with this phone
for maybe 15 minutes before i actually
noticed that the front buttons the
layout has changed so now it's a back
home and multitasking button no more
capacitive menu button all the menu
buttons will be in software now on the
screen and of course this carries over
into samsung's other tablets as well so
i guess it shouldn't really be much of a
surprise and speaking of buttons in a
very apple inspired move samsung went
ahead and put a fingerprint sensor in
the home button so this one you need to
swipe to use and basically once it's set
up it can be used to log into certain
secure apps like paypal or even
unlocking the phone itself surprise um i
kind of wish it would go a little bit
further than that like maybe i could log
into sites in google chrome using my
fingerprint and but you know that kind
of stuff is a while off i did notice
this new home button felt a tiny bit
less clicky a little bit less tactile
than usual like it was on the s3 or s4
maybe it was just my unit but hopefully
it's not quite as mushy feeling when
it's on retail shelves now another thing
they made a huge deal about is the
camera on the back of this guy so it is
a slightly larger 16 megapixel sensor
and a new dedicated image signal
processor so this shooter supposedly has
the fastest autofocus in any smartphone
clocking in at an average of 0.3 seconds
no idea how i'm supposed to verify this
but playing with the phone i gotta say
it definitely did feel like a quality
high-end phone camera and this is no
surprise coming from samsung really the
galaxy s4 had a great camera the galaxy
note 3 had an even better camera it shot
4k video and this new s5 is another step
up so 16 megapixels obviously the photos
are high-res it takes 4k video as well
and has some awesome new hdr processing
and selective focus modes and super fast
burst mode that took 30 shots and
probably about three and a half seconds
and a whole bunch more features as we
know samsung likes to throw every
feature in the world into their camera
now i couldn't really pixel peep and
judge the actual image quality from the
time i spent with it but i can guarantee
you that this is something that we'll be
taking a much deeper look at in the full
review but taking a look around the back
again you might have noticed some other
weird looking things below that camera
lens one of them yes is a flash but the
other two make up a heart rate monitor
so of course you have to use freaking s
health to take advantage of it but yes
you can hold your finger up to the back
of this phone for a few seconds and
it'll tell you your heart rate it'll
give you a heart rate reading not sure
how many people are actually going to
use this but that's samsung for you it
makes for a good ad it makes for a good
demo it's good to show off to your
friends so of course they built it in so
overall yeah messing around with the
galaxy s4 got that feeling that
performance is a little bit smoother not
faster but smoother uh so i'm getting in
mind that this really feels like
a galaxy s4 s
dare i say it yeah i said it it's the
galaxy s4 s uh it's got a ton of minor
conservative improvements a little bit
weird of a tweak to the design i'm still
not sure how i feel about it it's
obviously inspired by some other
manufacturers in some places but it's
just so easy to call this a galaxy s4
part 2. not that that's a bad thing you
know i guess people were just expecting
bigger changes that's all touchwiz
changes especially i mean you can see
here on top of android 4.4 touchwiz is
looking a little bit flatter a little
bit more toned down
even though there's still some crazy
stuff going on with the settings but
it's definitely still samsung ux and you
have plenty of samsung customizations
and samsung apps installed you even have
samsung's my magazine one swipe to the
left of your home screen like google now
on a nexus or blinkfeed on the htc one
so they still want you to use samsung
services and think of this as a samsung
phone and i'm not complaining i'm just
saying
so that's my first impressions of the
galaxy s5 of course there's much more
new stuff from samsung the new gear
watches
a new fitness band that looks pretty hot
actually you can expect to see this
phone advertised right alongside these
new wearables because they'll probably
want to make you buy them both at the
same time
but i'll have much more in-depth
coverage of the phone the accessories
the wearables and much more when it all
comes out in early april so definitely
hit that subscribe button below if you
don't want to miss that oh and hit that
like button if you enjoyed the video if
you liked it and share with your friends
let them know what's good with the
galaxy s5 this is the video to share
with them thank you for watching guys
hope you enjoyed and i'll talk to you in
the next one peace
[Music]
you